today we're playing king of the table
the winner stays on table first 11
points wins and there's a special rule
if you win three points in a row let's
go okay two same colors start
yeah okay you start
okay zero zero
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yo
enough room here
are you sure you don't want to come on
this side i think i think i'm good
thanks okay i need to get my first point
[Music]
oh that's how you do it where did that
come from i've never played this
background
[Music]
no my own my own
[Music]
yeah that was my third in a row special
rule
only forehand because your backhand is
so overpowered
[Music]
you thought you saw that fool to work
yeah when otto has to do footwork he can
do for her
[Music]
[Music]
well that was my sixth in a row should
there be like another special rule yeah
double special rule
right hand and only four hand there's no
chance i'm gonna win this point
i had to go for it
oh nice
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
pardon
[Music]
how many times in a row
[Music]
okay don't give me there
it feels like i've said that before
don't give me there
don't give me there
that's the biggest mistake you can make
[Music]
[Applause]
sorry this is unbelievable there's
nothing you can do
[Music]
no
[Music]
nothing with the story points
[Music]
yes
now that i deserve i deserve that one
[Music]
hey
[Music]
what was that block
my point match points
nice oh nice emil another match point
sorry
i also needed one you deserve that
probably yeah
so today the king of the table was the
sensei congratulations thanks anyway
remember to subscribe to our channel
here and watch our previous videos there
until next time